the 39-year-old pop star told a
california judge yesterday
she was forced to take the drug lithium
forced to perform
and forced to take birth control she
said quote
i wanted to take the iud out so i could
start trying to have another baby
but this so-called team won't let me
because they don't want me to have any
more
children in 2008 a judge created a
conservatorship requested by her father
jamie spears after concerns about her
mental health he had power over her life
choices until 2019
and now he shares control of her
finances and a court-appointed
professional oversees her personal
matters
jamie spears representative said
yesterday quote he is sorry to see his
daughter suffering
and in so much pain
and we're joined now by sarah wentz a
corporate attorney who special
specializes in conservatorship she is
not involved in spears legal proceedings
kevin frazier
host of entertainment entertainment
tonight also joins us good morning to
both you thanks for being with us
good morning good morning sarah let me
start with you i don't know did you
listen to the statement
that britney made yesterday about a half
an hour in length and
and what's your sense of whether a woman
who spoke
for half an hour of in with some anguish
about what she's going through whether
that woman should be
under conservative ship at this
i did listen to it and it was
heartbreaking to hear and
the most difficult thing for me was why
why they're at this juncture in this
hearing because
if her lawyer knew going into this that
this is what her
statement was going to be in my opinion
they should have been there
on a petition to terminate and not there
to talk about changing out the
conservatorship
yeah i mean what does it take to get out
of a conservatorship
typically in that statement brittany
asked that that she
she was able to do it without even what
she said without evaluation what does
that mean
when every person in the united states
is deemed to have the right to manage
their own financial affairs unless a
judge were to say that you're not
and in this case all britney would need
to do or brittany's lawyers on her
behalf
is petition for a termination now given
the fact that this has been going on for
13 years i would be surprised if they
don't actually
evaluate to make sure that it's
appropriate i understand that there's
probably things in the record that we
haven't seen
so i think it's really really unlikely
that they'll do it without
actually evaluating things in detail
kevin eureka here i know that you've
interviewed britney spears a couple of
times and
you understand the amount of money that
this woman has been able
to bring in at a time when she has she
doesn't have control
over simple decisions as she states and
as she stated yesterday at this hearing
uh can you talk about that and what do
you make of someone who's been able to
continuously perform
during this 13 years that she's been
under this conservative ship
well if you think about it since 2008
britney has put out four albums gone on
four world tours her
last world tour one of the most
lucrative in history
she had a four-year vegas residency she
has the fragrance that brings in money
her brother
claimed that it has made more than a
hundred billion dollars worldwide
but when you think about all that that
means that she is earning so much money
for so many
people and under this conservatorship
her father has said
he's increased her net worth from 2.8
million to 60 million dollars
in other words she's making money for
everybody and when you're making money
for everybody
they don't want it to end yeah hey kevin
uh it's tony decouple
britney made some pretty shocking
allegations in her testimony yesterday
what stood out to you
well there are two things and you heard
uh sarah mentioned that
she didn't really realize that she could
contest or end the conservatorship but
also
that her medication was used as a sort
of punishment
i interviewed brittany in 2006 in new
orleans she was helping victims of
katrina
taking them shopping she was a vibrant
young woman then
in 2008 december of 2008 at her birthday
party i
interviewed her again in my opinion she
was heavily medicated
and that was a red flag to us that this
woman was so heavily medicated but was
still trotted out in front of the
cameras
and i was really really surprised at
that and now hearing these statements
from brittany it almost confirms what i
thought and once again i'm not a medical
expert but i'm telling you what it
looked like to me
when i saw her that night in 2008 sarah
what do you expect to happen next in
this case now after this statement
i think probably the next step will be
that brittany is likely to get a new
lawyer
there was some alarming statements in
what i read yesterday about
the judge trying to explain to her
lawyer how he moves forward with the
petition to terminate
and that's pretty scary as a lawyer that
he didn't already understand what he
needed to do to get there
and brittany has tried to bring out her
own lawyer in the past and they've
refused to let her do that the next step
would be to file the petition for
termination
and the other side they could make this
easy on her her conservators could agree
to it and they could
accept a joint petition and the judge
could simply terminate it but i'm
guessing they're not going to do that
and what will probably happen
is this will go into essentially a mini
trial where they all present
evidence and whether this should stay in
place or not i
want to go back to sarah what i asked
you in the beginning though i mean when
when you listened to that statement that
she made
this doesn't really sound like a woman
who's not in control of her thinking
or can control making decisions i mean
is is
that's exactly right okay so this
doesn't typically sound like someone
who would need a conservatorship or does
it
no it doesn't and these types of
conservatorships are typically used for
people
who don't have the ability to manage
their finances never had that
or had something like alzheimer's or
dementia and aren't going to
regain their faculties this is not a
normal situation
in any way shape or form and i think
it's heartbreaking the things that she's
alleging if these are true i think we're
going to hear a lot more about what
happens with these conservators and the
role that they played in her lives
all right sarah wentz and kevin fraser
thank you both very much